good morning good afternoon good evening
to wherever you are uh thank you all for
joining us today my name is jeff
blankenberg
and this is an episode of alexa and
friends today i have the good pleasure
of being joined by kayoko yanagasawa who
is on our alexis
text to speech team thank you for being
here kyoko nice to meet you thanks for
having
me certainly so one of the fun things
that we like to do when we start these
interviews
is to dive right into some kind of silly
questions that uh let people get a feel
for who you are and and what your
personality personalities like a little
bit
and so the first question i'd like to
ask um i i don't know a lot about you
and i haven't had a lot of chance to
talk yet
do you have any kind of musical
background i notice you have some
musicians there behind you on your wall
um do you do you play any instruments
yes i played viola
yeah and i actually um made my own viola
oh my goodness you made your own wow
that's uh that's pretty cool i played
the clarinet uh when i was younger
um but i did not make my own clarinet um
i i had the clarinet that my grandfather
played
um way back in the 40s and then he gave
it to my father and then i
i took it and i still have it it's a
really nice old wooden clarinet
um but i haven't played it in many years
i think i still could though
well i haven't played it since then yeah
the reason i'm asking about your
musical background is because one of the
questions that i like to ask people is
that i want you to imagine for a moment
maybe you're in a
a small musical group or a band
and you've recorded your first album uh
of of unique music what would the name
of that first album your debut album
what would you call that album
um
so i was leading that band um i might
call it
kattan because
um so my first language is japanese and
um in japanese we tend to avoid pronouns
and um but young children when referring
to themselves they sometimes
um use their names so you um abuse
your name and um refer to yourself in
the third person so i might say kayoko
wants to eat kayoka wants to
um drink and but because i couldn't say
my name when i was younger i used to
call myself kathdan
and so that's how i started calling
myself
and that's what is that is that a
nonsense word in japanese or is that uh
does that mean something no it doesn't
mean anything okay
how i how i call myself and that's
how my parents call me that's very fun
my uh my parents always remind me i used
to refer to the
food spaghetti uh as pisghetti and so
yeah
even now when we get together with my my
family if we have spaghetti my mom will
remind us
of how i used to say that that's a great
story uh
okay so uh second question this one uh
is very insightful sometimes
uh i want you to imagine of all of the
superpowers you've ever heard of
superheroes having maybe in the comic
books things like that
if you got to pick one for yourself just
one superpower you don't get to be
wonder woman or superman where you have
lots of powers combined together
just one what would you pick
i'd probably pick being able to
manipulate time
so if i'm doing something that i really
like doing i want to
spend a lot of time on it sometimes i
don't want to go to bed because i'm
enjoying it so much
but if i'm at a dentist i'd want to get
that
over and done with as soon as possible
that's fair and
if you ask me an awkward question i
would
pause the time for everyone else to give
me time to think
and come up with answers i i like that
so it's almost like a pause and a fast
forward button
uh yeah very cool uh yeah i would i
would definitely be down
for that and uh i always like to ask
this question because
most superpowers can be used for good or
for evil
so how would you use that superpower for
good
like what's something that you could use
that power for to like
create something like do something good
for other people or something like that
um i guess it could be for good in many
ways
um like if i saw somebody
um like trying to attack someone
i could stop the time and remove the um
the about to be victim from i like that
that's a really good use of that power
that's excellent
it's always interesting it's very easy
to think of evil ways to use superpowers
right you could just pause the world
walk into a bank steal all the money
like that's an easy
kind of outcome right um and a lot of
people that want to invisibility
have the same thing right i can just
sneak and go around wherever i want to
go
there's a lot of benefits to superpowers
too that are uh positive all right
so we're gonna move on to my last one
this this one start the little story
and so i want you to imagine you're in a
big city uh
where in japan did you grow up well i
actually grew up in the uk
oh i apologize um so you learned
japanese but in the uk
um yes well at home i always spoke
japanese
yeah i grew up in sorry in the uk i
apologize for asking that
uh did you ever actually live in japan
yes yeah i was born in japan
okay okay so i was i was gonna use the
city i've been to tokyo
uh a couple years ago and i was gonna
use tokyo as an example it's a huge city
uh london is obviously a huge city as
well but i want you to imagine that
you're walking down a street and the
place that you need to go
in this huge city is one block over so
you need to
you need to either walk down the big
city block and around or you see there's
an alley and you could just cut down
that alley now it's a beautiful day
it's sunny it's a brightly lit alley
there's nothing dangerous about this
alley so you decide
you're gonna walk down this alley to the
next street over
and about halfway through this alley you
notice at the end that you're heading
towards that a giant
horse-sized duck appears in front of you
okay it looks a little aggressive it
doesn't look like it wants to be your
friend and so you
as anyone would you turn around and you
start to go back the way you came
only to realize that it has now been
closed by 100
duck-sized horses very small horses
right
so my question for you is you are now
trapped in this alley
um and you need to go one direction or
the other
which end would you choose to go towards
knowing that you're probably going to
find yourself in a small fight
um so anyone who knows me will tell you
how frightened i am
of any animal so even the cutest little
puppy i would run away from
it would be like a nightmare situation
for me
i would probably go for the what was it
a
horse-sized duck one big duck or a
hundred tiny horses
uh one big duck i'd probably go for the
one big duck and
um i because i can probably throw a
stone and distract that
duck oh that's not heard of anyone
trying to distract the duck that's not a
bad app that's not a bad option i like
that
i think it'll be easier to do that than
to try to distract a hundred
horses whatever i always like to get
people to think about the fact that if
you were just at the park and all of a
sudden you were surrounded by a hundred
ducks just normal ducks
that would be terrifying it is yeah that
is a lot of ducks 100 ducks
um all right well thank you for
entertaining me with those those silly
little questions i
i would love to get to know more about
you and so we're going to jump into that
next and uh from my my initial question
is i always like to ask people to kind
of give me their their quick four to
five minute rundown on what their career
has looked like
i think you more than some of the people
that we've had on here have probably had
a pathway that
led to where you are today based on your
education and things like that
but i'd love for you to kind of share
maybe where you went to college what
your focus was
and then um any of the major milestones
that kind of happened during your career
to god gets you to where you are today
so um to start where i went to college
um i went to
university in japan um so i mentioned
um earlier that i was born in japan but
grew up in the uk
so um i moved to the uk when i was
one and um when i was seven i moved back
to japan
and when i came back to uk at the age of
12
i'd forgotten all the english english
grammar and vocabulary
but the one thing i retained was
pronunciation
and that was the first thing that got me
interested in phonetics which is the
sound sounds of languages yeah and
i thought there was something special
about the human ability to speak
and that was the first thing that got me
interested in speech
and at school i learnt french and german
and learning a romance language in a
germanic language got me
interested in the differences and
similarities between those languages
and so when i went to university i took
up spanish
russian latin and ancient greek
and i majored in french but this was in
japan
um yeah i went back to japan for
university
and when you meant major in french or in
any foreign language at the university
in japan
you start from scratch because english
is their second language
and so people usually have no prior
experience of foreign
of other foreign languages and since i
already had six years of french under my
belt that gave me time to explore
other subjects like linguistics
phonetics and language science instead
of attending french lectures and
then as i was graduating i was torn
between
going on to a postgraduate degree and
going out to work outside of academia
and i thought if i
went straight into academia it might be
difficult for me to get out later but if
i go and
work outside of academia then if i had
the passion
i could always come back to do research
so
that's why what i ended up doing and i
landed a job as a journalist at the
nikkei which is a
financial newspaper company in japan and
this is where you might think
what right for me this was an important
step in my career
which steered me towards where i am now
it wasn't actually journalism per se
that i was interested in
and i'd actually applied to be a
proofreader at the company and this is a
person who
reads through stories that other people
wrote and corrects typos and grammatical
errors and does fact checks um i was
applying
um this position all along but after the
final interview
i was told that i'd got the job but not
as a proofreader but as a journalist
in the international news department and
um so i was basically hired for my
linguistic skills and so i then spent
some time
interviewing heads of states and other
political figures from abroad as they
visited japan
and i conducted interviews in english
and french
and just so that my colleagues don't get
the wrong idea about my french
proficiency i want to
and that my french has been going
downhill since i was 18 which was a
long time ago yeah and anyway after a
while
i started to miss life back in the uk
and i also felt a bit frustrated at the
lack of
dive deep in my day-to-day life so i
moved back to the uk
and did a masters and phd at ucl
university college london and
my master's was in phonetics and it was
an art subject but it gave me an
introduction to speech acoustics
and then for my phd i wanted to work on
something more speech technology
oriented
because during my years as a journalist
i'd had the opportunity to interview
someone who had started a company
developing speech recognition software
and so speech technology was a field
that i was intrigued about
and i knew that i wanted to work on
something that would have a practical
use
so for my phd i worked on the topic of
spoken language conversion with
accent morphing which essentially tried
to generate the speech of a person
in a foreign language whilst keeping
their speaker identity wow
and uh there i used texas beach
but was still not involved in developing
it
and as i was finishing my phd i found a
position
um at the in the speech team at
toshiba's r d
lab here in cambridge
and there i had the opportunity to work
on developing tts for the first time
and i worked on developing the front end
of tts for various languages
but the front end is the component that
converts from text
into a sequence of phonemes or sounds
and while i was there i had to i had the
chance to work on
um speaker adaptation for tts
and this was a steep learning curve for
someone from a non-engineering
background like me
but the the project gave me a good
overview
of the entire tts pipeline including the
back end which is the bit that converts
from
the sounds into an acoustic waveform
right
and it was also there that i had the
opportunity to learn a bit about
automatic speech recognition and um also
collaborated members of the computer
vision team to develop a talking head
synthesis system
which is a computer animated avatar
where um expressive speech synthesis is
synced with
facial movements wow and a siren
computer vision of fields
from which the tts have adopted
various techniques in recent years so
that was a valuable very valuable
experience
for me and then in 2016
i joined amazon's tts team and since
then i've been working on lots of
exciting and challenging projects
which i hope i'll have a chance to talk
about later yeah yeah for sure and so
what is it what is your official role
now i don't think i actually called that
out at the beginning
oh um my role is a speech senior speech
scientist
in the texas speech team at amazon and
um we work on texas speech voices for
amazon
including alexa and aws poly voices
very cool uh very very cool that's um
that's incredible a bunch of people in
the chat are
are commenting on just what a remarkable
career you've had and kind of the
exposure you've had to all of these
technologies it's absolutely amazing
it may sound random from other people's
perspective but i have
a theme which is an interest in language
and speech yeah i i
mine is not nearly that similar i have a
degree in psychology actually
um but while i was in college i should
have noticed that i was i was
taking classes like calculus and
computer science and those kinds of
things as
like a minor almost uh but pursuing a
psychology degree because i thought i
wanted to be a doctor my dad was a
doctor a dentist
and that was a path that i was i was on
as well
and i was getting a's in all of my
calculus computer science like hardcore
math science stuff
in my psychology classes i was getting
b's and c's and i should have put it
then um but i just didn't and so i
finished my psychology degree i got out
of school and realized i knew enough
about building websites and things to
kind of get dangerous and uh i went and
started building
some software and before i knew it uh
here i am at amazon
uh you know and i'm writing code every
day and building awesome stuff and
experiences on a lot of the technology
that you're working on
for uh for people to use on alexa so
it's uh very very cool
it's interesting what life takes us so
let's let's talk about that a little bit
so you mentioned that you have a
master's and a phd in phonetics
i i imagine there's a pretty natural
translation to that but how does that
help you in the domain of like speech
synthesis which is what you're kind of
working on
so phonetics is the study of sounds of
languages
and text-to-speech in its essence is
making computers speak
and um in order to be able to model how
humans speak we need to have an
understanding
of how how we speak and um
phonetic knowledge is crucial especially
in the tts front end
which is the bit that converts from text
into um
phonemes because we need to know how
letters correspond to sounds first of
all
um so we might have a lexicon or a
pronunciation dictionary
that defines how each word should be
pronounced but the pronunciation might
change depending on the surrounding
context
yeah um as a simple example when you say
10 pin
or 10 pins the n at the end of 10 is
more likely to be
m rather than no so
and that kind of knowledge needs to be
built into the tts system so that's
where
phonetics comes in useful and
previously a lot of these things were
coded as roles
and nowadays more and more of these
are being replaced by machine learning
models
but even then phonetic knowledge is
useful in analyzing
errors and discovering patterns so for
example
you might find that a sample synthesized
from a model
has issues in certain contexts before a
pause
and knowing that this happens with
certain classes of phonemes
helps you dive deep into the training
data in a systematic fashion
and also in tts because constantly
striving to make the synthesis as
natural sounding as possible
and in order to achieve that there have
been many advanced advancements
in terms of technology using various
machine learning approaches
but the motivation for many of these
machine learning
machine learning approaches often comes
from knowledge and
understanding about human speech
perception and production
which is what phonetics is about yeah
and so these are some of the ways in
which phonetics is important in the
domain of
tts and so i think um it's important
that
researchers with a phonetic or
linguistic background um
work together with researchers with
machine learning expertise
and we learn from each other yeah now
you said your your primary languages are
english and japanese
um and you've mentioned french
um i have two questions there that kind
of dig into this a little bit the first
one is
um how many languages have you been i
don't want to call fluent but like i
took french for nine years i would never
have called myself fluent
but like how many languages have you
been capable of speaking in your life it
seems like it's a lot
so um currently i would only say that
i'm fluent in japanese and english
um i used to have sufficient fluency in
french to be able to
conduct a business interviews um
but as i said my friend has been going
downhill since i was 18.
and then there's a bunch of languages
that i um
took up at university um i have
sufficient knowledge of the um like the
themology of the language um but i
wouldn't
say i was fluent like ancient greek for
example even as i was learning it
people asked me how to say hello in
ancient greek i had no idea but i could
say
um john was baptized or sure
it would be for conversation yeah yeah
no that makes sense and
are there specific languages that you
find um
give you more uh
insight or understanding of how like
when you're when you're piecing phonemes
together
are there ones that you tend to lean on
more as like well this is a foundational
way i think about this in
like ancient greek or english or or
japanese are there languages that you
tend to
pull from more than others uh when you
when you look at how to analyze these or
are they completely independent there so
there are groups of languages
families of languages um and um
like slavic languages have certain
similarities
um romance languages have certain
similarities and so on
but in general um the phonetics of
language is
very different from language to language
and so
in developing a tcs system um
you often have to have expertise in each
language now i've always heard that
english is a nightmare for a lot of this
stuff
which language have you found or at
least in your your experience has been
the hardest
so um in terms of um
learning to speak um so
i'm currently learning polish and i'm
finding it extremely difficult but
that's partly
um because i took it up late in my life
um
but in terms of um like how
letters correspond to pronunciation
polish is a very straightforward
language
so for a text-to-speech system um
from apparently from that perspective is
a straightforward system
um the hardest language that i've worked
on for texas speech is
japanese um
and the japanese writing system consists
mainly of three scripts
one of which is called kanji which is
basically chinese characters borrowed
into the japanese language
and kanji is highly homographic which
means that the same character
can be pronounced in many different ways
and it changes the meaning of the word
so if you imagine the word in english
the word spelt b-o-w it can be
pronounced bow
to mean bend forward or it can also be
pronounced bo
to mean shooting
the weapon they use for shooting arrows
or ribbons
and the meaning and tense of
pronunciation
varies from context to context and
japanese is full of
characters and words like that and
the majority of kanji characters have
more than one pronunciation
and in extreme case if you take the
character meaning
life or raw there are more than 150 ways
of reading that character depending on
the um
the context it's used in and so in order
to predict the pronunciation of japanese
words
hard coded rules are not not going to
cut it and we need machine learning
models and
humans learn these readings over a
lifetime so it's no wonder that
it's a challenge for these models right
and
another challenge is that japanese
doesn't have spaces between words
um in tts one of the first steps
in the tts front end is to split the
sentence into words
and in english you can um
deterministically do that
by looking for spaces but um
japanese strings words together with it
without spaces in between
so you need models to predict where a
word ends and the next word begins
and here again we use machine learning
models to predict the word boundaries
and earlier it mentioned that japanese
has three scripts
and one of them kanji has many readings
and this ambiguating pronunciation is a
challenge so you might be wondering
what about the other two yeah and the
other two
are called hiragana katakana and they're
what's called syllabaries
so the pronunciation is indicated in
these characters
but there's a catch an additional
complexity
is that japanese is a pitch accent
language which means that if
hashi or hashi the two mean different
things
one is chopsticks the other one is
bridge
and the pitch accent is not indicated in
writing
in hiragana or katakana so we do need
kanji
to indicate the meaning and implicitly
indicate the [ __ ] accent
and it doesn't end there because i still
have time to
um go out a bit more yeah so um the
pitch x of word can be looked up
in a dictionary a pronunciation
dictionary but the pitch accent can
change
when it's used in a phrase or a sentence
so here again
we're dependent on machine learning
models wow and so these present the
biggest challenges for tts when it comes
to accommodating the japanese language
and as i said i worked in developing the
tts from many
indo-european languages um in the past
but japanese has been the most
challenging one
um i've worked so far i would say so and
so i mean
it should be noted like you led the
development in the launch of the
japanese
voice for alexa right man that's
i mean that's an incredible number of
challenges to think about as i think
about the words
in english that i use um i can i can
sway the meaning of my sentence with
tone um not like you're describing
um i i might be able to add some sarcasm
or
uh like a slightly variant slight
variance on what i'm trying to say
but someone mentioned it in the comments
could you imagine messing those two
terms up and suggesting that we build a
bridge out of chopsticks
that's uh that's a really that's a
really massive difference in just a
slight tonation
yeah so that's a great challenge for
japanese and
even if you don't misunderstand the
context getting the pitch accent wrong
can
delay the customer's understanding of
what the texas speech
what alexa said and so um
leading to misunderstanding is really
bad but even if it doesn't
if if you don't get the pitch accent
right it leads to a very bad custom
experience
and um initially we had
um we didn't have a very good model for
the pitch accents
and um we had um feedback saying that it
sounded like a
um for an uh like a foreigner because
um foreigners for foreigners which
accents is something
it would be like he's trying to record
all of that would never work
i'm not a student of japanese at all but
it i mean it does seem to me like
um it would be very very easy to just
have
all the words come out properly but have
it sound like gibberish because it's not
the right tonality
is that that's uh do you find that as as
native japanese speakers there's a lot
of
interpretation that happens as you speak
because you have to make sure that like
that that you understand the right
tonality like you hear the word and
maybe they didn't say it with the right
tone so they said
the word it could either mean chopsticks
or bridge but clearly in the context it
means bridge so i know what they're
talking about is there a lot of that
happening as you listen to something yes
totally um as human speakers we we're
doing that all the time and i'm always
amazed at
how clever we are as human um
listeners and uh speakers to be able to
do all of this
and it is teaching machines to do that
is so difficult
yes yes well i'm glad you're the one
doing it and not me because this sounds
impossibly hard
uh so a couple a couple of months ago i
got to speak with andy breen who's our
senior manager of tts research
and we talked a lot about some of the
more recent speech advancements like
alexis speaking style adaptation
making her sound more natural that's a
big thing for us um can you tell me
about what you're working on
yeah so we've been working on a model
that enables the same voice to speak
multiple languages
and we we've launched alexa in 15
locales
but each language has at least one alexa
voice
and that's because tts voices are based
on
recorded speech from voice talents and
in order to ensure that alexa sounds
native like
in each language we have a different
voice talent for each locale who can
speak that language fluently
and this means that the alexa voice
speaking spanish for example
sounds different from the alexa voice
speaking english
and with the new multilingual model that
we've been working on
we can now have the same voice speaking
spanish and
english and this is actually what we
launched a few weeks a
few weeks a few weeks ago yeah okay
so back in 2019
we launched the multilingual mode for
alexa
in us english and us spanish which lets
customers address alexa
in either language and receives a
response in the same language
but as i mentioned before the english
and spanish responses were in different
voices
and as a result the muslin mode felt
like
speaking to two different people sure
and with the new model
we took alexa's multilingual
capabilities a step further
and we introduced a multilingual mode
that uses the same voice
for english and spanish even though we
only had english recordings from the
voice talent
and this is a nice link to the work that
i was doing for my phd more than 10
years ago
even though the technology we're using
now is very different and much more
advanced
wow that is uh that is very cool so
let's let's dive into that a little bit
we've got this capability where we're
able to see speak to the same voice in
different languages
different accents they should sound
native in both places
how does that actually work so this has
become possible because of neural texas
speech
um which might have come up in uh
previous interviews that you've done
with um like andy
um so we use neural networks
to generate speech directly from
phonetic renderings of
input text and early versions of alexa
use concatenative methods which means we
string to
string together tiny snippets of
recorded speech
and with traditional tts systems
one way to make voice speak another
language was to map the phonemes
of the target language into equivalent
phonemes in the
speaker's native language but this
resulted in a heavy
heavy foreign accent and another
approach
was to find bilingual voice talents and
record them speaking both languages
which is not always feasible
and limits the number of languages that
we can combine
and so our new muslin model based on
neural tts
solves both problems and
in the past few years the amazon tts
team have
used mtts to transfer uh vocal
inflections or what we call prosody
to uh from a recorded recorded uh
voice to a synthesized voice or to
change the speaking style
of a synthesized voice to make it sound
more like a newscaster
or a dj and in the same way
ntts lets us transfer spanish
spanish-speaking capability
with native speaker accent and fluency
to another voice
which has no spanish recordings and
although we're using the technology
initially in a bilingual mode
um experiments we've done indicate that
it should generalize to multiple
languages
wow so you could potentially have one
voice that could speak eight languages
mentally yes oh my gosh that's uh that's
so cool
so let's let's get into that machine
learning a little bit um
how how do you train a model like that i
mean this seems
like an impossibly hard challenge but
i'm very interested to hear how
how do you go through that process so we
train
um a model on recordings from multiple
speakers in multiple languages
and we start with our standard neural
dts platform
which is an encoder decoder architecture
with a tension mechanism
and we take as input a sequence of
phonemes
so the phoneme sequence is passed to an
encoder
which outputs a vector representation
that encodes
acoustic information about the phonemes
and
we want this encoder to project
acoustically similar phonemes from
different languages
into the same region of the
representation space
regardless of speaker identity or
language
and in addition to the phoneme sequence
we use two additional inputs
a language id code and a speaker
embedding
um so speaker embeddings are a vector
representation
that encodes the characteristics of a
given speaker speech
okay and the embeddings for similar
speakers are meant to cluster together
independent of the language that they
speak so the system
can use these embeddings to extrapolate
how speakers
might sound like in different languages
and so then the the phonetic phonetic
encoding
together with the language id and the
speaker embeddings
are then passed through an attention
mechanism
and the decoder then uses a speaker and
language embeddings to produce the
correct acoustic content for a
particular speaker
and language and so that's the
gist of how it works but um if you're
interested in more details
we've published a blog post in amazon
science so um
it has a diagram which might make it
easier
cool and so for our audience um oh uh
aaron just posted this in the chat but
you guys can find the link there but if
you're looking for any articles on this
kind of stuff like the science behind
how
alexa and a lot of the research that
we're doing at amazon
you can find that at amazon.science it's
a website we have a blog there's all
sorts of great information there
and i know kyoko has a blog post
specifically on that that aaron just
posted in the twitch chat
i will i'll pop that here on the screen
as well
it's amazon.science and the article is
called english language alexa voice
learns to speak spanish so you can
you can try and type that link in for
what i just put on the screen or you can
click on the link that's here on twitch
i don't know if aaron is also posting
this to linkedin and facebook and
youtube the other places that we're
broadcasting but
um if she is you'll be able to find
those there
all right so um this is
i gotta be honest there's a lot going on
there right as we talk about
all of this processing and speaker
embedding and language ids all of these
pieces are
are pulled together i think one of the
most
amazing pieces of this for me is that
all of this is done in milliseconds
right i mean i i think being able to
accomplish these tests i've been in
software a long time in my career
there are things that just take time and
this seems like one of those things that
i have to reference a bunch of data
i have to look at models i have to pull
all this information together and i have
to do it
like that uh that's amazing to me
is there anything special or unique
about our approach to be able to do it
so fast
or is that just the i don't know a lot
about building the the underpinnings of
machine learning engines but
i'm curious is there anything special
about what we do that
optimizes for speed so we
there are several machine learning
approaches that you can use
and um there are we not only look at the
performance in terms of
um accuracy or in the case of polyglot
not only accent and naturalness and
similarity
but we also look at um like the latency
and
memory consumption um so
we do a thorough testing um in those
aspects too
in order to um not um
in order to be able to provide the
response um immediately without the
customer feeling
any um delay no that's great so speaking
of customers what what does all this
mean so we do all of this work to think
about
like multi-language multi-voice what
does that mean for customers so
what what is it the that really solves
for them
so um in practical terms so there are
two multiple modes for
multilingual modes for um
spanish-speaking customers in the u.s
we have english slash espanol us and
espanol
english us and customers can now select
the language option
english espanol us to get the same voice
speaking english and spanish
and if they prefer this separate voice
experience like before
they can select the espanol slash
english us option
and we hope that this will lead to
improved custom experience because you
can get the same alexa voice regardless
of
whether you're speaking spanish or
english
and this technology opens up the
possibility for us to have the same
voice
same tts voice speaking many languages
like you said
whilst keeping the same voice and but
of course this may not make sense and uh
we're always driven by customers so
we'll keep an eye on what customers are
saying and use the technology
in a way that will be most useful for
them yeah now i've heard we do something
similar in india right we have hindi and
we have english
um do you know is this following a
similar process
so the the voice that we have in um
india
um uses the traditional um approach what
one of the traditional operations that i
um mentioned earlier we recorded
bilingual voice talent
got it very good um all right so
i think it was inner speech 2020 you had
a publication that you authored with
uh some of the members on your team it
was about singing synthesis
which is another really interesting
thing to talk about so
what other advancements do you see on
the horizon for speech technology
because i
i didn't imagine synthesizing a human
singing voice was something we would do
soon but here we are
so uh talk to me about that
so with neural tts it's now possible to
have more consistent
and smoother synthesis than before but
the neutral style which is the
standard speaking style for tts systems
can be boring
and the real advantage of mtts is its
adaptability
and versatility so for example um the
tts team at amazon have published work
on
style synthesis and emotional synthesis
using neural tts
and these these are ways in which we're
working to make tts more and more
natural and as close as possible to a
human
and the work on singing synthesis which
i mentioned
takes that approach further and explores
human
vocal capabilities beyond speech wow
and i think tts will also in future be
able to understand and be aware of the
context
and dynamically adapt to it and
this would enable tts voices to speak in
a way that is appropriate
not only for the context of that
isolated sentence but in the context of
the previous dialogue
or adapting the customer's mood and
i also see the technology um
that the technology will probably grow
in areas where there's a past human
capability
like we have seen with the multilingual
model so
this is a technology that allows the
um the same voice to speak many more
languages
than an average person can and this has
been made possible by the power
of machine learning and its ability to
learn from data
and uh transfer the knowledge so
when we talk about the average person
we're obviously not talking about you
we're talking about the average you like
you're far above the average when it
comes to speaking languages but uh
this this is so exciting yeah
the thing advanced as what advancements
in technology have made it possible to
expand the tts capabilities in
many different ways and for example
there might be a technology which will
make it possible to produce
non-speech sounds like laughter
interjections and other
paralinguistic sounds and
these are some of the ways in which the
technology could evolve in the future
but at amazon we like to be driven by
and guided by customers
so once we find some space where the new
technology makes customers
lives better i think there's lots of
things that we can do with the
technology
but we need we also need to be aware
that customers expectations will also
be changing and so the bar is constantly
rising
but we'll always try to do what's right
for the customers
and i think that's the right approach
it's amazing to me how often being an
amazon employee
that question comes up in a meeting what
do our customers want do we have data
have we talked to them do we have
feedback
um and one it's amazing that we do have
feedback people customers are really
willing to let us know
what's going on what they think and how
they feel about our software um but then
how we can turn that into actually
improving our products for them is
is amazing that's something i find
really exciting about working at amazon
getting customers feedback and um
working on that feedback to provide
something better
i very much agree um all right so i
think as we wrap this up i want to talk
about
science careers in general a little bit
with you um
if you were talking to a young
professional or a student that's
embarking on their career or thinking
about this i i have this
exact scenario happening in my home i
have a seven my daughter turned
seventeen today
uh i cannot believe that i'm hoping
thank you i can't believe that i'm old
enough to have a 17 year old child but i
do
um and she is very interested in finding
a way to work
at nasa um she likes engineering she
likes
computer science i think that she'll
probably find her pathway there
but uh at 17 she's still got a long road
ahead of her
so if you were giving some advice to
someone like her
what would your advice be for thinking
about getting into career options in
science
so um at amazon we have something called
the leadership principles
which we use in um as you know every day
we use every day in all kinds of
situations whether we're discussing
ideas for a new project or deciding on
the best approach to solve a problem
and i think many of these qualities are
important as a scientist too
so i'll just mention a couple of them
the first one is
dive deep so as a scientist diving deep
into problems
is probably something that comes
naturally to you and something you enjoy
doing anyway
but when you're swamped at work or when
you're under pressure to meet a deadline
it's easy to overlook this so this is
something that i have to keep telling
myself
and um there's a quote by einstein that
goes
the more i learn the more i realize how
much i don't know
yes i like this process of learning more
realizing i don't know anything becoming
curious asking questions
and learning more which takes us to the
next point which is
learn and be curious so by repeated
process of diving deep
you become an expert in your field and
being an expert in your field is
important but i think it's also to have
a broad perspective
so looking back at my career i feel like
i was
always putting myself in a position
where i knew
i needed to learn more and being in that
position gives you the opportunity to
learn more and expand your knowledge and
skills
and as a scientist this is something
that you probably enjoy anyway
um and in previously in texas speech
we adopted a lot of the techniques
employed in speech recognition
and nowadays more and more machine
learning techniques are applied across
different domains not
just speech and we're using approaches
developed outside of the speech domains
which means that we see researchers from
completely different backgrounds
joining us in tts and it's great that we
have scientists with
varied backgrounds in our team now
because it helps us have a wider
perspective
and we can learn so much from each other
yeah and
as a scientist your skills are flexible
and you can apply a similar technique
for solving problems
in many different areas so say don't be
afraid of looking for opportunities
outside of your specific area of
expertise and calling out to that
specifically i think that's something
that
people forget about in their careers is
that like there's a lot of people that
identify with their job or their role
and they're like i am this
right and i think the people that are
the most valuable the people that have
the most success in their careers are
the ones that recognize that we are
all problem solvers in civic domains
and the more that you think about how
can i solve problems in my domain
whatever that may be
um will allow me to have the freedom and
flexibility to move and do the things
that i want to do because i
i'm a good problem solver yeah that's a
skill that is not
uh emphasized enough at least in united
states educational institutions like
high schools um i don't think they focus
enough on problem solving they focus
way too much on memorization and rote
learning um
it would be nice to see more problem
solving driven development
or of education for sure and great
so is there anything outside of the
learn to be curious dive deep do you
have any like there's always some
non-technical aspects to
like careers that really call out to
people or anything i'll give you an
example of one that i use all the time
um and that is to it's it's build a
network
um eat people go out of your way this is
something that is always big advice for
me
um is that you know there are groups of
people talking about
everything i would bet that there are
scientists meeting virtually or in
person that get together and they talk
about hard problems and
network with each other and when you
need a new job you're like you know what
i met that person at this cool thing i'm
going to reach out to them because they
seem like they're doing some cool work
so building a broad network don't don't
just live in your little bubble but
broaden it as much as you can is my
biggest piece of advice for people what
do you what do you have
i think mine is similar um so mine would
be
to um mine would be about communication
so regardless of whether it's a career
in academic academia or in the industry
communication skills are crucial for
example when explaining about your work
to
your managers who may not necessarily be
from the same background
or if you go to a conference you might
have to describe your work to someone
from outside your field
and you need to be able to see things
from other people's perspective
and explain your work clearly and also
collaboration is crucial in research and
there again communication skills are
essential yes
i think um always keep in mind the
synergy that comes from
communicating well with others yeah and
i think i think that comes together the
problem solving
if you think about the word empathy um
it can carry a lot of meaning it's not
always just feeling
the emotions that others are feeling but
it's being able to recognize from
someone else's perspective how they
they think and act and behave yeah and i
think that that's a that's also a big
piece of what you're describing here is
the idea of being
empathetic to others and being able to
understand what their perspectives are
um i have a i'm a new uh leader on our
team
and she just made this interesting
comment about how when someone offers
you criticism
our natural instinct is to deny it like
that's not true i'm not like that i'm
not that's not
uh who i am but she said it's it's
really interesting to be able to flip
that around
and instead say how is that true how
people then perceive
my behavior or my action or my writing
or whatever it is um in the way that
they described it and
it's it's an interesting way to flip it
around because you really start to take
into consideration what other people
have uh have on their minds and how they
work
i think that empathy also brings it back
brings us back to the
problem-solving um point that we talked
about
we try to think about um how to
solve different problems but using um
similar techniques that we've used in
different
area so you're trying to sort of change
your perspective
so i think there's something in common
there very very much
all right so i know there's a bunch of
interesting launches launched blog posts
that have been out there about tts on
the amazon.science website
um if any of you that are watching would
like to learn more about those
announcements
about what kayoko or the alexa science
team are working on um
or if you have any that we have lots of
scientific endeavors that are constantly
being worked on and shared in white
papers and other things
please visit amazon.science i can't
recommend it enough there's a lot of
really great interesting information
there
uh things like these interviews are also
posted there so you'll have an
opportunity to find
our past catalog of interviews like that
uh but kevin i want to thank you so much
for spending time with me today this has
been
eye opening for me for sure and i think
for our audience based on the comments
that i've seen
um this was this was a fantastic
conversation thank you so much for
sharing your thoughts
thank you so much for having me and
thanks everyone for joining
certainly all right well that's it for
today for alexa and friends i want to
thank you guys all for tuning in
uh we will be here again next week um
and every week hopefully going forward
lots of interesting guests lots of
interesting things to talk about
um so on behalf of kayoko and i thank
you guys all so much for tuning in today
and we'll see you all again very soon
bye